sometimes in your search for happiness
you ponder the meaning of your life you
sift your memory for beginnings you
send your mind ahead for directions
but all you really know is now
and you are lost in the president
Who am I how did I come to be time where
does it take me toward death and
then what where did I come from
to understand why you are here you must first
understand your beginnings at birth you did not
suddenly flare into existence out of nowhere you
have always lived in pre-earth life you were with
your Heavenly Father there as his spirit sons and
daughters you lived until you were ready to come
to earth as the poet Wordsworth said our birth
is but asleep and are forgetting the soul that
rises with us our life star have had elsewhere
it's setting and cometh from afar not in entire
forgetfulness and not in utter nakedness but
trailing clouds of glory do we come from God who
is our home upon entering mortal life the memory
of your life before birth was blotted out that
you might live by faith and further prepare for
the everlastingness of life this mortal body in
which your Spirit now dwells is subject to pain to
difficulties to death for it is through opposition
that you grow in strength of character you must
know pain to appreciate well-being difficulties
to develop courage death to understand eternal
life you then whoever you are are related not
only to every person upon this earth who lives
who has lived who will yet live but to God the
father of a soul and to his son our Savior with
your acceptance of the responsibility of earth
life you were given a wondrous mortal body in
the likeness of God so God created man in his
own image in the image of God created he him male
and female created he them and the spirit and the
body are the soul of man as sons and daughters of
God is it any wonder that you are an eternal part
of his plan and purpose and coming from such a
noble heritage that you have possibilities far
beyond your greatest dreams be assured that your
personal search for happiness has real purpose
be assured that your life is worth living
life offers you two precious gifts one is
time the other freedom of choice the freedom to
buy with your time what you will you are free
to exchange or allotment of time for thrills
my trade it for base desires invested in greed
you may purchase with it vanity I may spend your
time in pursuit of material things yours is the
freedom to choose but these are no bargains
or in them you'll find no lasting satisfaction
every day every hour every minute
of your span of mortal years must be
accounted for and it is in this life that
you walk by faith and prove yourself able
to choose good over evil right over
wrong enduring happiness over mere
amusement and your eternal reward
will be according to your choosing
a prophet of God has said men are that
they might have joy a joy that includes
a fullness of life a life dedicated to
service to love and harmony in the home
and the fruits of honest toil an
acceptance of the gospel of Jesus
Christ of its requirements and Commandments
only in these would you find true happiness
the happiness which doesn't fade with
the lights and the music and the crowds
God has placed you on earth without memory
of your pre mortal past but he hasn't left
you without hope or without faith in life
after death this he has promised you I am the
resurrection and the life he that believeth
in me though he were dead yet shall he live
one of the best attested facts of sacred history
is the resurrection of the Lord Jesus Christ three
days following his crucifixion the disciples
were gathered together as recorded in Scripture
then the same day at evening being the first day
of the week when the doors were shut where the
disciples were assembled came Jesus and stood in
the midst and saith unto them peace beyond to you
and when he had so said he showed
unto them his hands at his side
then were the disciples
glad when they saw the Lord
just as you lived before mortal birth just
as you now live in this life soul through
the love and sacrifice of your Savior
do you continue to live after death
like every member of the human race
you were born and you must die your
birth is a matter of record you
take it for granted but death
that uncertain door that leads ahead
has been for man and awesome mystery
life's greatest test comes with the death
of a loved one and without faith in the
immortality of the soul the separation
of death looms forever comfortless
after death though your mortal body lies in
the earth you your spirit self being eternal
continue to live your memory of this life will
remain with you and the knowledge of your life
before birth will be restored like coming out
of a darkened room into the light through death
you will emerge into a place of Li awakening
and find loved ones waiting to welcome you
so here you are on earth with no memory of
what went before and only faith to whisper
what comes after be assured that you are here not
by accident or chance but as part of a glorious
everlasting plan by a still small voice within you
and through revelation to his appointed prophets
God our Eternal Father guides the affairs of
his children today as in the past in 1830 God
reestablished his church and restored the fullness
of his gospel once more among men through a modern
Prophet Joseph Smith by revelation our Savior
made known again the plan of salvation and
exaltation salvation comes as a gift to every man
through Jesus the Christ but exaltation which is
the highest of eternal opportunities you must
earn it is not enough just to believe in Jesus
Christ you must work and learn search and pray
repent and improve no his laws and live them
this is the way to peace and happiness and
the fullness of everlasting life it is your
heavenly father's way we invite you to explore
it to test it to pray and search and seriously
consider prove all things hold fast that which
is good only if you are unafraid of truth can you
find it but it leads to limitless opportunities
with your loved ones with you always and forever
therein lies your happiness a happiness deeper
than passing pleasure a happiness beyond the
understanding of man a happiness not of the
moment but of eternity this is every man's
search this is the purpose of life this is the
key to happiness for the God and father of us all
has said this is my work and my glory to bring
to pass the immortality and eternal life of man